the grief is so familiar it's felt by
thousands of families caught up in this
drug war
Nerissa pour in your own me Kamiya nuit
she's talking about the death of her
eldest son Marcelo one of four young men
apparently killed by police officers
here in the pyatters Hills young men
don't go shopping and are not 1985 Oh
Philip Asia non 2016 treinta you know
palang she she tells us seven armed
officers in civilian clothing came here
in late August while the young men were
playing cards despite having no
jurisdiction in this location the
officers claimed they'd found evidence
of illegal drug use she shows us where
the young men were taken and shot one by
one in so many cases that would have
been that with no one left to challenge
the police account but something almost
unheard of happened here one of the men
survived his name is Ephraim Murillo the
officers it said dumped the bodies here
and what they didn't realize is that
Ephraim Murillo was still alive he'd
been shot in the chest it was playing
dead and in the time that they weren't
looking he was able to scramble down
this valley very steep valley to the
stream below and then back up and get to
the road where he was able to persuade
someone to take him to hospital he's now
preparing to testify against the
officers for obvious reasons his lawyers
have been keeping him in hiding
but Ephron's father and the families of
the men killed and living in fear even
after an unprecedented court order was
issued that banned officers from
intimidating them their sense of danger
remains in deep wound
Machado impunity Mariana we do see langu
McNally bond Tahu in diamond uniform nd
nothing nada
but the lawyer representing this case
says this is just the beginning the next
step will be to really file criminal
charges against the the killers and that
would mean he will be filing murder and
frustrated murder charges against them
so as far as you're concerned as a
lawyer there is no question that this
was a case of cold-blooded murder
definitely this is say nothing but
cold-blooded murder create carried out
by men in uniform it is just the latest
in a series of scandals that have
implicated the Philippines National
Police last week President dieter Tay
suspended all police drug operations
claiming up to 40 percent of officers
were corrupt in recent days he's
continued to publicly shame what he
calls rogue cops but critics say the
culture of impunity is of deter tase own
making having previously welcome to the
mounting death toll can even pledge to
go to jail himself in place of accused
officers this isn't just about
corruption these police officers your
men have been given a green light to act
in whatever way they see fit by the
president isn't that the case no I don't
think so because the president's did not
say anything about going beyond the law
what happened now some policemen go went
beyond the law look at us now the
President did not tolerate anything of
it but for all the defensive Ness
justice still feels distant in places
like this the case of Ephraim Murillo is
the first serious legal challenge to
deter tej drug war but it's unlikely to
be the last the verdict about what
happened here will have resonance far
beyond
Tom Rayner Sky News Kazon City